so we have some actual good news out of
Israel despite the fact that it may sort
of take a while until anything really
comes of this and the news is that the
longest-serving Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has been indicted on charges
of fraud bribery and breach of trust now
as many of you know Netanyahu has been a
road block to any kind of serious peace
possibilities in Israel for a very long
time and not only the the not the only
roadblock in the circumstances that
present themselves there but a pretty
massive one particularly given his
alliances with some of the most extreme
right-wing elements in the Israeli
Knesset and he has now been indicted
this is the first prosecution in Israel
of a sitting Prime Minister and
politically things in Israel are very
hectic there have been two inconclusive
elections maybe going to a third vote
this has been going on for almost three
years with regard to possible charges
against Netanyahu and the charge is now
finally materializing now the obvious
question that most people would ask is
well what now does he leave what happens
next it's unclear this is widely
uncharted territory for now he can
remain Prime Minister if convicted he
would have to step down but it could be
three or even four years until a
possible conviction would happen and
that doesn't even account for the
possibility of appeals so this really
could be a very long time and it's going
to be more about financial but I'm sorry
not financial pressure although maybe so
give it given the level of corruption
he's allegedly involved in political
pressure it may be more about political
pressure in terms of actually making
change happen Netanyahu is apparently
planning to stay for the time being he's
immediately using very trumpian language
to describe the entire thing he's
calling it a witch hunt he's calling it
an attempted coup he wants the
investigators investigated I mean it's a
carbon carbon copy of the rhetoric that
we've seen Donald Trump employ around
investigations and allegations into his
misdeeds but then there are also some
pressing practical political questions
number one Benjamin Netanyahu is a
member of the Likud Party does the Likud
Party lose confidence in Netanyahu and
say he has to go
there are elements within the Likud
Party that are saying we need a
different leader but so far the official
position of Likud has been they're
standing by Benjamin Netanyahu what
might the quickest way B to get
Netanyahu out probably if Likud says
they're picking a different leader which
they could do at any time but again
right now it's not obvious that they're
going in that direction if Benjamin
Netanyahu stays in power it would not be
surprising that he would try to get
himself immunity through a congressional
procedure through the Israeli Knesset
but there is no Knesset right now in the
sense that Benjamin Netanyahu has not
been able to form a government since the
last election so it is a complete and
total mess what we do know what we can
say for sure is that Netanyahu has been
a disastrous prime minister from the
point of view of moving forward on peace
and some kind of even steps towards
breaking the impasse of the
israeli-palestinian conflict now every
time I talk about this if I don't
mention the both sides somebody gets mad
at me there's no question that Hamas and
Gaza has also been a disgusting
impediment to moving forward but no
matter that we still have to point out
that Benjamin Netanyahu has no
credibility as an even potential arbiter
of peace and he has to go if we want a
shot and hopefully that will be
precipitated by this although we don't
know I've said before Benjamin Netanyahu
is allied with the most extreme
religious right-wing elements of the
Israeli Knesset that is not a group that
is likely to oversee any serious
advancements in breaking the
israeli-palestinian conflict impasse
there's no credible path to a lasting
peace deal of any kind as long as
Benjamin Netanyahu is not only there but
again under indictment on these charges
Israeli politics is complex it's
unpredictable
it's not obvious what the next step will
be again a conviction on these charges
is unlikely to be the fastest way to get
him out since it could take three to
four years for an initial conviction and
then there can be appeals so this is
going to be a long one the
idiot news is of course good we have to
understand that this will be a very slow
process which might in the immediate
change very little or something could
happen likelihood saying Netanyahu's out
here's our new leader which might
actually bring change more quickly there
is probably more to gain by trying to
seat a new government then trying to
wait around for a Benjamin Netanyahu
conviction but some good news although
it's unclear how quickly it will bring
any change forward we'll follow it for
sure